what are the character roles that you've
auditioned for in the last six months
i've really been getting into characters
that i think that i'm right for for the
industry right now so it's been like the
teenage girl
or um what was it the mean girl because
they love me as a mean girl or the
really sweet bubbly girl
so co-star roles like that and i'm
really excited because i'm finally
getting into the things that
i feel like i'm right for i've played a
daughter i've played a soldier
i'm currently working on a project where
i play an iraq war veteran with ptsd
and so i've played the love interest
i've played
i played a lot of different characters i
must say um and i think
i've also
been very cautious of certain roles um
i don't want to
i'm not desperate to play any type of
role i want to try to um
humanize these characters
and i'm attracted to characters that are
multifaceted
and
frankly i've been given a lot of those
opportunities i've auditioned for like
the
the school girl
um
the girl next door so those two are
usually ones that i auditioned for
the two main ones yeah that they like
give to me that's all i get do you know
what i mean it's been
lots of moms and nurses and doctors that
kind of thing drug cartel boss
to
mobster you know mafioso like italian
mafia also not too much but i would say
like the cleaning crew
the janitor types i think it would
always be like the best friend i would
say the best friend of the protagonist
so always supporting more or less
because the protagonist uh was required
to be caucasian or white and i'm not
white so
i don't get nervous
much in auditions
and i'm again there for a job and i'm
fitting a job description so i don't
take any of the rejection personally um
i would see me as again the every girl
the every woman the kind of
chameleon if you will that you can put
her in a
in judge robes
you can make her into
gosh
i played a mafia
girlfriend
you know i mean there's just
that whole range
of me that i can kind of fit into so i'm
hoping that they see
the diversity
um but i think probably what they see
always is a mom or a wife or those kind
of things
but it does depend on how i dress so if
i can have the opportunity to dress for
a character i will spend a lot of time
getting the right look to give them a
different impression and that's helped a
lot
you